do you think it takes i'm gonna ask both
of you what do you think it takes for a
man to be a husband
status
i think status status and leadership
i think
because um
how can i say this
and they
i think women want they want to be able
to rely on
rely on a man
and
to able to adapt to any situation that
they're given
that's what i think
what do you think it takes for a woman
to be a wife
um
i think
the listening aspect of it is really
important i think i agreed with you
earlier when you're talking about that a
woman who can listen
um
i don't know i need to sit with that
question it's not it's cool because you
know it's everything's a learning
experience yeah definitely um it is so
when it comes to like marriages right
um
there's a lot of
people tend to think they're pretty not
a pre-nappies
people think that a prenup is like a bad
thing
if you're getting into a marriage would
you
as a man sign a prenup i feel like
it's a fail safe
but
if you do it
is it a set of a failure yeah we're
talking about earlier is a risk right
does that imply marriage is a risk i
think she's like
would i set a prenup that's the question
i don't know
but i feel like if i do
i'm going to i'm going into the marriage
having the idea that this won't work
so if you if you get car insurance does
that mean that you you can you know
you're going to have a crash
that's a really good point
it's just i'm the days and shorts it you
don't you don't know what happens
but like i don't know what happens you
don't have a relationship there you go
yeah but um
so why is it offensive now
to get a prenup and it's not a phantom
to get car insurance he's like saying no
but i'm a good driver i'm not going to
have a crash i'm a fantastic driver
you're right we're actually right on
that one
would you sign a prenup next time
um
i don't know there's your answer right
there
like that the hesitation of the
so you've been with your guy for for
instance you've been with him for like
three years
and he said you know what babe he gets
out on one knee and you know this is a
man that you want to be for the rest of
your life
and
he proposes to you and you say yes
and then you guys start you know saving
for the wedding or whatever money and he
says babe do you know what yeah like i
want to get married to you i love you
boo boo boom but i think we need to like
think about a prenup i think that's a
sensible discussion to have
how do you think you'd feel as a woman
if your man came to you
trying to tell you to sign a priest
because he's basically saying this is
what he's basically saying he's been
saying
that some i'm gonna do this but if it
don't work i don't take it as that
though i take it as a level of security
i i'm someone who loves stability and so
if you're coming to me with a kind of
energy that's like
well
actually i care about my finances and i
care about what happens yes i love you
and i don't want things to end between
us but at the same time i still want the
insurance and the stability that
god forbid something goes wrong
i will still be okay i think i would
respect that and the fact that he comes
to me for a conversation before
just saying that we should do it i think
i respect that even more do you know um
the advantages you as a woman have with
a prenup um no i don't okay so that's
sorry do you want it yeah because you
you actually know here we go you know
should this relationship break down you
know exactly what you're going to get
you know what you're going to get i i
don't think she does
that's why that's the point she doesn't
know that so i don't like no because a
prenup is basically a contract mm-hmm
and it's a sign and there's stipulations
within the contract as to what you're
going to get or what you're not going to
get right and so
the thing is is that basically you're
giving away your right to get half of
everything he owns yeah and essentially
there'll be other things within the
contract that will you won't be able to
have by signing that pre-number so for a
lot of women it's like well this is my
if i don't sign it then i'm good if
we break up
but
yeah
meaning
you can take half of a man's wealth
if you don't sign it
but if you do sign it
it may not just it may not be half now
the question now becomes okay i think
for someone i think goes back to one of
my points where i was saying earlier i
want a balance for my personal life that
i still want to have that successful
career side so for me it's not an issue
i don't need your half because i've got
my own i i just want to say
shout out to dr dre because he's got
he's in the city he's in that situation
right now where his wife is getting
money
from him did you know that the richest
women in america she is she riches no
did you know that the richest women in
america are
divorcees do you see that
pre-nup
mad you know you know it's a good way to
get a bag but still so do you think now
marriage is becoming a business then for
women i can't lie
today
no even
wouldn't you even think right now that
like marriage marriage is a business
move
for marriage is because it is it is a
businessman because from a contract's
being signed there's a business deal
going down there you go but
jeff bezos got divorced
uh
um bill gates she got divorced dr dre
got divorced
right
tiger woods got divorced
there's so many successful men
that have put in
work to create their business and yes
their wives were there while they were
putting in the work right and i
personally believe you are
you should get a portion of this because
if i have given you a certain type of
lifestyle right however
you became accustomed to a certain type
of lifestyle because of me yeah you are
no longer with
me
so the lifestyle after me ain't gonna be
the same however a lot of the time women
think you have made me accustomed to
this lifestyle
the operative word being
you
have made me accustomed to this
lifestyle so i now want to continue this
lifestyle for the rest of my life i
think that is
is stupid
because i think you just answered the
original question then i think that's
why a lot of women are so angry with ali
because they're saying that they're
saying okay i'm i'm going to be
submissive to these men i'm going to be
the housewife i'm going to do all of
these things he's going to be the
provider living this lifestyle for me if
he now leaves what am i going to do what
do you mean if he now leaves is the
majority of women i'm uh initiating
divorce but i'm saying i'm saying i'm
saying
you're taking that point i don't believe
that i'm saying you're taking that point
that answers that answers you don't
believe that what like majority of women
i personally don't like i don't think i
don't have that mindset okay cool
whether you have it or not but that's
the fact it's not no i don't know but
that's not what i said when i said i
didn't believe it
it's not meant to initiate divorces it's
men that are saying let's keep this
thing together regardless of what we're
going through let's keep it together
it's women that are saying no i'm on on
i'm unhappy and i'm going to go and see
the grass screen on the other side nine
times out of ten when women leave a
marriage right they're leaving with
children
they're leaving with the man's home
they're leaving with all of these things
which make them feel happy
but they're going now into a marketplace
to try and get a relationship
right
however
generally
men are looking at that woman with their
kids and everything may look good but
he's thinking
that's not my life
that's not my like i've said this before
and it can be a little bit controversial
men over
i have a thing men between the ages of
19 and 29
should not be getting with a woman that
has children okay right because those
are the years like you like you are that
you're trying to build who you are as a
human being right build my family you're
trying to build your foundation you
shouldn't be taken on someone else's
foundation right before your own yeah
after the age of 29
you gotta decide as a man if you're
looking for a woman in and around that
age she's probably going to have a
childhood the question is do you think
men really want that though men
generally do not want to take care of
another man's child generally they don't
i've done it myself like in my 10 year
relationship that i was in the woman
that i was with had she had a child from
a previous
i raised her child
for as mine for 10 years while also
having our own right
so i understand
what men's psychology is from actually
doing it
and then being outside it and looking in
it and be like you know what
nah that's a little bit
it's a little bit weird so i'm saying
when it comes to men getting with women
with children
i'd say the the illness now relies on
you after the age of like 30 to say you
know what
how often is it i'm gonna find a woman
past the age of 30. they ain't got no
children yeah
do you know what i mean
but you don't have to you men can go for
a younger version they can go for a 25
year old
not not a lot of men can do that
not a lot of men can do they can do what
like go for younger people for younger
women i think they can because women are
attracted to older men yeah
younger women
100
it's true okay i hear that i hear that
but
how can i say it
how can i say this one
you have to come back to me let me think
about my heart yeah yeah as a young
woman you know you're attracted to older
men right
that's a general rule
so that's why the masculinity you see
more together right a man a man can be
in his 40s and bag a girl that's 28.
okay yeah
like no no no it's not even a problem as
a man there i've been there don't die
no no no no no no i've seen you know
what you mean because you're more
established yeah i've seen it you've had
more eyes on yourself yeah however a 40
year old woman
if she's bagging a 25 year old man it's
just for sex yeah that's sugar baby
that's a she just wants she just wants
to have a sugar baby
you know i'm saying it's not like i want
to have a relationship with this guy
that's true so like that's why men's
they say men's value
increases as they get older and women's
value decreases as they get older wow
and that's what and that's think that's
why a lot that's what kevin samuel
that's what that's what he's kevin
samuels had those women on there there's
no danger zone
all them thing there he said that but
women didn't like it they didn't like
hearing the truth
and that's like women generally don't
like
they don't like hearing that truth and
the thing is it may sound harsh but
it is what it is once you get past a
certain age
you're going to be looking into men in
their 50s 60s you know i mean if you're
in your 30s and you've got like a couple
children etcetera etcetera
you may want to start looking older not
younger you see that as not not to be
rude because
they see it as baggage in a way
yeah
yeah
so